>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
IF YOU WANT TO UNDERSTAND A
COUNTRY'S MILITARY, MILITARY
OFFICERS ARE JUST WAR FIGHTERS,
THEIR TRAIN TO BE THINKERS, SOME
OF THEM HAVE ADVANCED DEGREES.
IN RUSSIA, OFFICERS ABOVE THE
RANK OF COLONEL ARE REQUIRED TO
READ A BOOK BY A RUSSIAN
NATIONALIST CALLED THE
FOUNDATIONS OF GEOPOLITICS.
THE BOOK ENVISIONS A EURASIAN
EMPIRE WITH RUSSIA AT THE CENTER
AND OUTLINES THE WAY TO ACHIEVE
THAT.
IN CHINA, RECRUITS ARE TOLD TO
READ THE ORIGIN AND GOAL OF
HISTORY.
IT TEACHES THAT TIME IS
SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE IT'S CULTURE
IS SUPERIOR TO THE WEST.
YOU MIGHT NOT AGREE WITH THEM,
BUT THESE ARE SERIOUS BOOKS, AND
SPREAD MOUNT THE NATIONAL
INTERESTS OF THE COUNTRIES WHOSE
OFFICERS READ THEM.
WITH THAT IN MIND, WHAT ARE
AMERICAN MILITARY OFFICERS
MEETING THESE DAYS?
LET'S SEE, A SUB LITERATE INPUT
ON HOW THE YOU UNITED STATES IS
A DISGUSTING MORAL COUNTRY THAT
MUST BE CHANGED IMMEDIATELY AND
FOREVER.
THAT IS "HOW TO BE AN
ANTIRACIST."
NOW THAT HE IS RICH AND FAMOUS,
GOES BY HIS REVOLUTIONARY NAME.
AT THE BOOK IS GARBAGE, IT'S NOT
JUST EMBARRASSINGLY STUPID
COMMENTS POISONOUS.
ANY SYSTEM THAT PRODUCES UNEQUAL
OUTCOMES MUST BE LITERATE.
HE APPLIES IT TO EVERYTHING.
SOME PEOPLE MAKE MORE MONEY THAN
THE OTHER PEOPLE, THE ECONOMY IS
A RACIST.
THERE AREN'T ENOUGH BLACK
ASTROPHYSICIST, ASTROPHYSICS IS
BAD TO FINISH IN BASIS.
IF IT RAINS AND A BLACK
NEIGHBORHOOD BUT NOT ACROSS
TOWN, THAT IS WHY THE RACISM.
HE DIDN'T REALLY WRITE THAT,
PROBABLY BECAUSE HE HAS NO
DETECTABLE SENSE OF HUMOR.
THAT BOOK IS THAT MILITANTLY
DOWN.
HOW DO WE RESPOND TO ALL OF THIS
RACISM?
HE PROVIDES A SOLUTION.
THE ONLY REMEDY TO RACIST
DISCRIMINATION IS ANTIRACIST
DISCRIMINATION.
HE ACTUALLY BROKE THAT.
IN OTHER WORDS, HIS BOOK AGAINST
RACISM PROMOTES RACISM.
HE WOULD THINK THAT WOULD BE A
RED FLAG FOR PEOPLE,
CONTRADICTING AS IT DOES THE
FOUNDING PRINCIPLES OF THE
COUNTRY AS WELL AS BASIC HUMAN
DECENCY, BUT NO.
PEOPLE LOVE THE BOOK, IT'S ALL
OVER CORPORATE AMERICA.
YOU COULD PROBABLY PICK UP A
FREE COPY AT YOUR HR DEPARTMENT
TOMORROW MORNING IF YOU WANT.
THE MILITARY?
YOU CAN'T IMAGINE THE U.S.
MILITARY WOULD ASSIGN A BOOK
LIKE THAT, RECOMMENDED IT TO
EVERY SAILOR IN THE U.S. NAVY.
WHILE YES, ACTUALLY.
ON TUESDAY, JIM BANKS OF INDIANA
DEMANDED AN EXPLANATION FOR THIS
FROM THE CHIEF OF NAVAL
OPERATIONS.
HERE'S HOW IT WENT.
>> KENNEDY'S BOOK STATES THAT
CAPITALISM IS ESSENTIALLY
RACIST, AND IT'S CLEAR THAT
RACISM MUST BE ELIMINATED.
YES OR NO?
DO YOU PERSONALLY CONSIDER
ADVOCATING FOR THE DESTRUCTION
OF AMERICAN CAPITALISM TO BE
EXTREMIST?
>> HERE'S WHAT I KNOW, RAISES
SOME IN THE UNIT --
>> YOU RECOMMENDED EVERY SAILOR
IN THE UNITED STATES NAVY READ
THIS BOOK.
>> I'M NOT FORCING ANYONE TO
READ THIS BOOK, IT'S ON A
RECOMMENDED READING LIST.
>> DID YOU READ THE BOOK?
WHAT PART OF THIS BOOK IS
REDEEMING AND QUALIFIES AS
SOMETHING THAT EVERY SAILOR --
>> HE'S CRITICAL ABOUT HIS OWN
JOURNEY AS AN AFRICAN-AMERICAN
IN THIS COUNTRY.
WHAT HE'S EXPERIENCED --
>> LET ME ASK YOU AGAIN.
DO YOU EXPECT AFTER SAILORS READ
THIS BOOK THAT SAYS THE
UNITED STATES NAVY IS RACIST
THAT WE WILL INCREASE OR
DECREASE MORALE, COHESION AND
RECRUITING RIGHTS IN THE
UNITED STATES NAVY?
>> I THINK WILL BE A BETTER NAVY
FROM HAVING OPEN, HONEST,
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT RACISM.
>> Tucker: OPEN AND HONEST
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT RACISM?
THAT WOULD BE NICE, BUT IT'S AN
AMUSING LINE COMING FROM SOMEONE
TO HAVE READ KENNEDY'S BOOK, AS
HE SAYS HE HAS APPEARED OPEN AND
HONEST CONVERSATIONS ARE RACIST,
KENNEDY SAID THAT MANY TIMES.
LET'S SAY OPEN AND HONESTLY,
CARE MORE ABOUT THE WAY PEOPLE
BEHAVE THAT IN THE WAY.
YOU TOOK MARTIN LUTHER KING AT
HIS WORD AND JUDGE THEM BY THEIR
CONTENT OF THEIR CHARACTER AND
NOT THE COLOR OF THE SKIN.
IF YOU DO THAT, YOU ARE RACIST.
THE CLAIM OF NOT RACIST
NEUTRALITY IS A MASK FOR RACISM.
THE LANGUAGE FOR COLOR BLINDNESS
IS A MASK TO HIDE RACISM.
A COLOR-BLIND CONSTITUTION FOR A
WHITE SUPREMACIST AMERICA.
NO, OPEN HONEST CONVERSATIONS
ARE NOT ALLOWED.
YOU ADMIT YOU ARE A RACIST, OR
ELSE YOU ARE SUPER-DUPER RACIST.
SOUNDS PRETTY DERANGED,
HONESTLY.
IN FACT, IT SOUNDS LIKE AN
EXTREMIST IDEOLOGY, JUST LIKE
THE MILITARY'S ALWAYS WARNING US
ABOUT.
THE PENTAGON IS INVESTIGATING
NATIONAL GUARDSMEN WHO POSTED
UNFASHIONABLE OPINIONS ON
FACEBOOK ABOUT THE LAST ELECTION
OR MAY HAVE VOTED FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
WITH ALL THEIR INVESTIGATORS
RUNNING AROUND LOOKING INTO
THESE CRIMES, HOW CLOSELY HAVE
THEY LOOKED INTO KENNEDY?
HAVE THEY CHECKED HIS
SOCIAL MEDIA HISTORY?
THEY ASKED THAT QUESTION.
WATCH.
>> IN COLLEGE, KENNEDY STATED
THAT WHITE PEOPLE ARE A
DIFFERENT BREED.
OF HUMANS.
AND ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE AIDS
VIRUS.
YES OR NO, DO YOU PERSONALLY
CONSIDER THE THEORY THAT WHITE
PEOPLE STARTED AIDS TO BE AN
EXTREMIST BELIEF?
>> I WOULD HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
THE CONTEXT.
I'M NOT GOING TO --
>> THIS IS A BOOK THAT YOU
RECOMMENDED EVERY SAILOR IN THE
UNITED STATES NAVY --
>> YOU CAN'T TAKE QUOTES FROM
SOMEBODY'S BOOK, I'M NOT GOING
TO DO THAT.
>> Tucker: DO YOU CONSIDER THE
STATEMENT THAT WHITE PEOPLE
CREATED AIDS AND EXTREMIST
STATEMENT?
I CAN'T COMMENT ON THAT.
[LAUGHS]
ANY CONTEXT FOR THAT.
THE ADMIRAL -- THE MEDIOCRITY --
WILL NOT OFFEND THE MAN HE HAS
JUST BEEN PROMOTING TO THE
ENTIRE U.S. NAVY.
THAT'S ODD, ONCE YOU DIG A
LITTLE, YOU CAN SEE WHY HE
DOESN'T WANT TO TALK MUCH ABOUT
IT.
NOT LONG AGO, KENNEDY WAS
INVITED TO SPEAK AT THE ASPEN
IDEAS FESTIVAL, A ROOM WHERE
IDEAS GO TO DIE.
ONE PERSON DARED TO ASK THE MOST
BASIC QUESTION I HAVE ALL, HOW
DO YOU DEFINE RACISM?
YOU THINK YOU WOULD BE READY FOR
THAT QUESTION, BUT HE WASN'T.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID.
BECAUSE YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
IMPORTANT OF DEFINING RACISM,
BUT UNLESS I MISSED IT -- WHICH
IS POSSIBLE, I DIDN'T HEAR YOUR
PERSONAL DEFINITION, IS THERE
ONE THAT YOU WOULD OFFER US,
LIKE HOW DO YOU DEFINE RACISM?
>> RACISM, I WOULD DEFINE IT AS
A COLLECTION OF RACIST POLICIES
THAT LEAD TO RACIAL INEQUITY,
THAT ARE SUBSTANTIATED WITH
RACIST IDEAS.
[LAUGHTER]
SHARE, A COLLECTION OF RACIST
POLICIES THAT LEAD TO RACIAL
INEQUITY, THAT ARE SUBSTANTIATED
BY RACIST IDEAS.
>> Tucker: SO RACISM IS A
RACIST STUFF.
OR AS KENNEDY PUTS IT, AND WE
ARE QUOTING, IT'S A COLLECTION
OF RACIST POLITIES THAT ARE
SUBSTANTIATED BY RACIST IDEAS.
RIGHT.
BUT HOW ARE WE DEFINING RACISM?
KENNEDY COULDN'T SAY.
IF DESPITE MAKING A BOUNTIFUL
LETTING ON THE TOPIC, HE HADN'T
THOUGHT TO HOW TO DEFINED THE
WORD.
IN A SERIOUS SOCIETY, EVERYBODY
LISTEN, EVERYONE IN THE ROOM
WOULD'VE WALKED OUT AND FOUND
SOMETHING BETTER TO DO,
BIRDWATCHING A B.
THE SO-CALLED INTELLECTUAL ON
THE STAGE TURNED OUT TO BE AN
IDIOT.
THEY SHOULD'VE LEFT.
THEY JUST LAUGHED NERVOUSLY,
THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT SOMETHING
WOULD HAPPEN IF THEY POINTED OUT
THAT HE WAS A FRAUD, THEY WOULD
BE DENOUNCED.
THIS IS HOW MEDIOCRE PEOPLE
CONTROL ENTIRE SOCIETIES, WITH
IMPLIED THREATS.
TO GO ALONG, OR WE WILL PUNISH
YOU.
THEY DON'T SAY ANYTHING.
THE FUNNY THING IS, IN HIS OWN
BOOK, HE ADMITS HE HIMSELF IS A
RACIST.
HERE'S A DEFINITION.
WHAT DEMOCRAT STOOD ASIDE AND
LET BUSH STEAL THE PRESIDENCY
AND DESTROYED BLACK VOTES?
BUSH'S TEAM TRANSITIONED THAT
WINTER, I TRANSITIONED INTO
HATING WHITE PEOPLE.
WHITE PEOPLE BECAME DEVILS TO
ME, BUT I HAD TO FIGURE OUT HOW
THEY BECAME TO BE DEVILS.
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE THAT
ADMIRAL MICHAEL GILDAY HAS ANY
POWER IN THE UNITED STATES
MILITARY, BUT HE DOES.
THIS IS THE MAN, THIS IS THE MAN
HE BELIEVES THE ENTIRE U.S. NAVY
SHOULD STUDY.
IMAGINE WORKING FOR SOMEONE LIKE
HIM.
MOST PEOPLE CAN'T IMAGINE THAT,
SO THEY ARE LEAVING THE
MILITARY.
>> WONDERING TOLD US THAT
MILITARY HISTORY SESSION WAS
REPLACED WITH MANDATORY TRAINING
ON POLICE OR CHILD BECOME A
WHITE PRIVILEGED, AND SYSTEMIC
RACISM.
SEVERAL OFFICERS ARE LEAVING THE
UNIT SETTING THAT TRAINING.
SOME UNITS WERE REQUIRED TO READ
WHITE FRAGILITY WHICH CLAIMS,
WHITE PEOPLE RAISED IN WESTERN
SOCIETY ARE CONDITIONED INTO A
WHITE SUPREMACIST WORLDVIEW.
A UNIT WAS FORCED INTO A RACIST
EXERCISE CALLED A PRIVILEGE WALK
WHERE MEMBERS OF THE WING WERE
ORDERED TO SEPARATE THEMSELVES
BY RACE AND GENDER IN ORDER TO
STRATIFY PEOPLE BASED ON THEIR
PERCEIVED PRIVILEGE.
>> Tucker: DEPRESSING IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IT.
GOOD PEOPLE DRIVEN FROM MILITARY
SERVICE, MANY OF THEM SERVING
GENERATIONALLY AS THEIR FATHERS
AND GRANDFATHERS DID, BUT HAVING
TO LEAVE NOW PURELY BECAUSE OF
THE EXTREMIST IDEOLOGY OF ITS
LEADERS.
IT'S CRUSHING, IF YOU THINK
ABOUT IT.
IT'S ALSO SCARY FOR ALL OF US.
WE NEED THE MILITARY.
IF THE PENTAGON IS ESSENTIAL TO
THE SURVIVAL OF THE COUNTRY.
BUT THE COMMISSARS IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DON'T CARE, THEY
ARE NOT SLOWING DOWN.
THEY ANNOUNCE ITS NEW MISSION
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH SPACE.
THE NEW MISSION IS ABOUT
APPLYING PRINCIPLES IN KENDI'S
BOOK.
AT THE NEW MISSION IS EQUITY.
>> AT NASA, WE AREN'T A MISSION
OF EQUITY LAUNCHING OUR
OPPORTUNITY.
>> EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO
CHALLENGE AND INSPIRE.
TO REACH WHERE WE'VE NEVER
REACHED BEFORE.
>> TO USE SCIENCE, DATA AND
TECHNOLOGY TO ADVANCE EQUITY.
>> TO SHATTER BOUNDARIES.
>> AND BREAK DOWN BARRIERS
ACROSS AMERICA.
>> WE HOPE YOU WILL JOIN US ON
THIS MISSION.
>> T